[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we're live here in Liverpool at the
labor Party Conference
we certainly know what Liz trust stands
for after the Chancellor's bombshell
Budget on Friday that of course included
the biggest tax cuts for half a century
so the key question this morning is what
will case starma's response be how
radical is the labor leader prepared to
be on the weekend when the country is
listening to find out if this is a
government in Waiting well we'll try and
find out what happens next with our
guests this morning here in Liverpool
[Music]
we'll be joined here at conference by
the former labor leader and now Shadow
energy and climate change secretary Ed
minibans
[Music]
we'll also be speaking to the greater
Manchester mayor possible future party
leader Andy Burnham
and the chancellor wants new legislation
to clamp down on Union activity with
more strikes on the way we'll be joined
by the General Secretary of the UK's
biggest Union Unison that's Christina
mcaney
I'll also be joined here live by the rmt
union general secretary Mick Lynch
following his recent meeting with the
new transport secretary about those
upcoming rail strikes
plus we'll be talking to one of the
original architects of Labor's most
recent period of national election
success so Grandy shall we say of new
labor Lord Peter mandelson
[Music]
thank you
hello good morning well our first guest
dominated headlines across the UK two
years ago when his battle with the
gunman became overcovered became
symbolic of a disconnect between
Westminster and the North and the mayor
of Greater Manchester has campaigned for
greater investment and autonomy for his
region and of course the northern
economy in general the former Health
secretaries also sometimes touted as a
potential future labor leader well he
joins us now I'm delighted to say the
mayor of the greater Manchester Andy
Burnham thank you very much for being on
the program this morning and it feels
right to start with the budget this week
a pretty extraordinary really ripping up
treasury Orthodoxy and also a big
departure from Boris Johnson's brand of
concern to them as well what did you
make of it yeah
to be honest Sophie I I can still barely
believe what we saw on Friday we're in
the midst of the worst cost of living
crisis we've ever experienced you know
people in this part of the world in
Greater Manchester their heads are
slipping beneath the water they're
living just using their microwave not
using the cooker they've changed their
life dramatically a survey disabled
people in Greater Manchester last week
said that over half have cut back what
they're eating because they can't afford
to eat and then you have a budget that
splurges billions on the wealthiest
people in the country and actually
doesn't do anything meaningful to get
people through the autumn in the winter
so honestly I can barely believe it it's
you know having been through a period of
national Unity the way I would describe
it Friday's budget was a flagrant Act of
vandalism on the social cohesion of this
of this country the government has drawn
battle lines with working people they've
told us which side they're on I think
labor conference now has a chance uh to
to pick up that that battle speak for
ordinary people and in doing so I think
uh put the government on borrow time
okay so you say that their dividing
lines have been drawn and labor needs to
use this opportunity at conference so
quite clearly then do you think labor
thick should commit to reversing the tax
cards if Labor's in government
well personally I would have said this
wasn't a time for tax cuts this was a
time to use what money was there to help
people for instance on benefits there
should have been an uplift to Universal
Credit as we saw I just want to come in
again if I may I just want to come in if
I may because it was a really good
should labor commit to reversing the tax
cuts if you're in power
I thought I think I answered it I said
yes this wasn't the time the time for
tax cuts I I think money needs to be in
the system now to help people
but if I may that's not that's not quite
the same I think they should I I'm
saying that they so yes they should
because okay yeah I said that but I said
that in the answer to the first question
I was coming on to say you know we've
got a situation where public sector pay
is nowhere near inflation so we've got a
potential for a wave of industrial
dispute over over the um over the winter
that money should have been used instead
to help people with their pay packet so
they can continue to go to work for us
in the NHS or continue to service on the
front line in the fire service without
worrying about what's going on in their
own home that is what the money should
have been used for to help us through
a cost of living crisis and I think
they've made that I think the
government's made the wrong choice in
this moment and it's left millions of of
people at risk at risk this winter lives
honestly are on the line we'll have a
huge Mental Health crisis if nothing
changes and that should have been the
priority targeted support for people to
to get people through this period rather
than than just giving away billions of
pounds borrowing billions of pounds uh
for bankers and billionaires I mean it's
just obscene it really is obscene and I
would see labor this week come together
kissed arm has put us in a position
where we can win the next election this
is the first conference over since we
left left government where I think it's
odds on that there could be a labor
government within one or two years so
we're in that position and The Time Is
Now not to draw battle lines with
ourselves the government's drawn battle
lines with us and with ordinary working
people let's unite and take the fight to
them in Liverpool this week
so you're saying there could be a labor
government within one or two years and I
just want to be crystal clear and
forgive me if I you know you obviously
feel that you've answered but I just
want to be crystal clear for myself are
you saying that that labor government in
one or two years that you believe it
will be it should reverse the 1p cut to
income tax and reverse the change to the
45p rate
yes I am saying that because I don't
think it's the most targeted way of
using the resources that we've got at
this moment in time I would use it
though to support people in different
ways so I'm not saying we wouldn't put
money in people's pockets but if you
keep that money you are then able to
Target it for those who most need it
because obviously if you cut the 20p
rate it benefits it benefits not as
targeted a measure as doing other things
such as supporting people who are at
real risk and that those are people on
Universal Credit you've got to sort out
public sector pay you can't leave kind
of millions and millions of people in
the public sector providing providing
Services we all depend upon who who
themselves can't make things add up you
just can't do that that's the recipe for
chaos in our Public Services over the
winter so that that is my position I
don't think it was a time for tax cuts I
think this is a time to support people
through a crisis
um I want to talk a bit more about the
kind of policies that you would also
like to see I I know that you are
planning on bringing the buses back
under at National control uh public
control should say in what in Manchester
and last month you told my colleague Kay
Burley that there's a case for
renationalizing the energy companies as
well is that what you want to do
well it follows on from what I was just
saying Sophie because we've got to a
position in this country where people
can't afford life's Essentials they
can't afford water they can't afford
energy they can't afford gas to cook as
I was saying before and they're just
using a microwave they can't afford to
travel by bus and they certainly can't
afford to travel by train and I think if
you go back to the 80s people warned
about this that if you lose control of
these services in the end the price will
go up I don't think the services
improved to be honest with you and
certainly with rail it's gone massively
backwards and you've got to I would say
have more public control of the basics
so that you can make them affordable to
Ordinary People and it's not just words
because as you say we've done that in
Greater Manchester I have taken the
decision to put buses back under public
control and that comes in a year from
now but in advance of that we've already
brought in a fair cap so that people can
afford to use use the buses and we have
a system of Affairs that is similar to
London so that is what we are we are
doing and I do think it's right to be
open-minded about more public control
more public ownership so that we don't
leave ourselves so exposed to to energy
costs as we are at this moment in time
um it's interesting isn't it and there's
a big focus on green energy at this at
conference we'll be talking to Ed
miliband about that a little bit later
as well and the new policy uh saying
that they want to commit to Net Zero
electricity by 2030. given the public
anxiety about bills do you think that's
the right Focus
well if you combine it with what I was
just saying by doing it through more uh
it doesn't have to be National ownership
of course you could Empower bodies like
mine to take a a bigger stake in the
development of of new renewable energy
let me say this this is a good bold
policy from kirst armor and Ed miliband
this morning this is the right way to go
face up to the future rather than going
back to the past with with fracking
which by the way would really impact on
an area like this where I'm talking to
you from now a former mining area
fracking would disproportionately affect
the north of England it's backward
looking but it's also divisive and
that's why I say embrace the future and
Labor's doing that and I think they need
to really explain how this policy could
get people's energy bills down and make
us more energy secures I'm sure they'll
do a conference this week and that's
exactly the kind of policy that I think
labor should be putting forward as well
as that immediate help for people
through the cost of living crisis
okay we'll be talking to everyone about
that a bit in a bit more detail later
it's interesting you're talking using
this as an example of a bold policy and
you've been talking that to be fair
about quite bold policies yourself like
National nationalization for example
more public ownership and being clear on
tax policy as well
we know well there's trusts and quasi
quateng stand whatever you think of what
happened on Friday it was a pretty
radical uh budget no one's going to be
left in any doubt about what they stand
for do you think that labor needs to be
I guess a bit Bolder in its approach
this weekend
well let's trust and quasi quaten were
Radical radical but deeply wrong and I
would go so far to say immoral I don't
see how you can possibly justify a
package like that when as I said before
the heads of millions of people are
slipping beneath the water I just don't
understand how you can possibly uh put
that forward uh it's it's Brazen it's
the drawing of battlelands as I say with
ordinary people so this is the time for
labor to to move up and set out an
alternative that people can support and
so I I want to be clear you know I'm
supporting here I want the party to
unite here in Liverpool they've got us
in a position where we've got a clear
and sustained pole lead which is no
small achievement it's a it's a big
achievement and I think the government
has now opened up a huge opportunity for
labor to put out a program that connects
with ordinary people so yes I would say
be be bolder uh be clear about what we
will what we will do I'm a little
disappointed to hear the party saying
that it's it's going to rule out
electoral reform I I think I would say
to them listen to hear the mood of
conference on that particular issue I
hope conference will still vote in favor
of that because we've got to maximize
the chance here of a labor-led
government but I would also just say for
people who doubt the case for for
electoral reform over the summer we have
just seen the most graphic demonstration
we've ever seen of how a small number of
people a small Elite can manipulate the
political system in their interests and
that's what we saw on Friday this was a
budget for Bankers this was a budget for
Tory donors that is what has happened in
this country and this is what labor now
can say to the public look we're going
to change things we're going to reform
the way votes work we're going to reform
the way politics works and we're going
to make it work for you and these are
our policies that we're going to do
right now to help you through this this
biggest cost of living crisis we've ever
faced cost of living crisis we've ever
faced you've clearly got ideas uh that
you want to see at Labor moving towards
you tempted to come back to Westminster
and put them into action I couldn't help
but notice there's a by-election coming
off in West Lancashire after Rosie
Cooper and Andrew stepping down he
attempted to throw your hat in the ring
well I said I would do a full second
term in Greater Manchester and I'm in
the middle of that and to be honest with
you it's it's so energizing what we're
doing you know we're making change
happen here you know that decision to
put buses under public control that is
where my head is right now we are in the
middle of a massive performance between
transport
what about um what about in 2024 when
your term comes to an end
well my term is still going in 2024 so
you know as I say that's where my focus
uh my focus is I've be honest with you
Sophie I've said I've not ruled out
coming back uh one day but I've made
commitments to the people of Greater
Manchester I'm going to see those
commitments through
to read that you said you felt imposter
uh syndrome during a time at Westminster
before uh I just wonder if you could you
know I'm sure that's something that lots
of us including myself can
um really relate to
um has that changed do you think you'd
make a good prime minister now
I think um people are kind of seeing the
real me more
um you do get that sense of feeling you
know do I really belong here when you're
in that Westminster system because of
the way it is
um I can't be the first person to have
to have felt some of that but also I
think the way it works isn't helpful for
connecting politics to people because it
it makes you vote in a way that you
might not necessarily fully believe in
because of the whip system or you have
to say things to take the line that the
party wants you to take and I think you
kind of get to a point where the public
will think well who is this person
because you know does he really believe
all of these things I think Westminster
does that it the risk is it makes a
fraud out of people because you're
always kind of doing things you half
believe in or you don't fully want to
say and I feel much more liberated and
clear out of Westminster about what I'm
about what I'm trying to do for the
people of Greater Manchester but the
bigger reforms I think the country makes
and I I've stopped sort of you know kind
of speaking in code if you like you know
I you I thought you thought I was
speaking in code at the start of this
interview but I wasn't uh you know I was
I say now what I think is is needed uh I
hope that's a helpful independent voice
if you like you know without all of the
kind of the the the the
um the strictures of Westminster holding
me back I just think it's it's
beneficial for politics to have people
like me in these mayoral positions we
can speak for people from The Real World
as you said uh at the start of the
interview and I think that's a helpful
blast of reality into into Westminster
at times which doesn't always uh operate
in that way
I've been told that I I need to run out
of time but I just want to squeeze in
one uh more a very quick one if I may um
Mr Burnham you know you were talking
there about the kind of experience
you've had as mayor do you think you
might make a better crack at the
leadership now than you did last time
when you obviously failed to win
well I I didn't just lose once uh Sophie
as you remember I lost twice so I didn't
make a very good good cracker at all did
I so um you know I as I say I've kind of
taken a step outside I think it's been
to to my uh to my benefit I wouldn't
rule out one day going back as I've said
I'm just just going to be honest about
that and I probably am a a better
politician I think anyway these these
days because as I say I'm not kind of
caveating everything I'm not sort of
second guessing everything I'm just
calling things as I see them and just if
I could say finally when it comes to the
government you know I don't play they
think I always play Party politics I
don't if the government gets something
right I will say so such as the help
they're giving us to reform buses that's
right thank you that's the right thing
to do but when they get things wrong I
will call things out as strongly as I
can and what they've just done as I say
again it's obscene it's a moral throwing
billions at the richest people in this
country at this moment in time it's a
recipe for I think serious serious
issues over this winter and that's why
the labor movement now needs to unite
and fight it okay understood thank you
very much Andy Burnham there talking to
us from labor conference well that is at
the mayor of Manchester's view let's
find out uh what the shadow cabinet view
uh shall we because uh Ed miliband who
is the shadow energy and climate change
secretary is here this morning they've
unveiled a new uh green uh policy I
haven't either I'm sure you'll be very
keen to talk us about in a moment I just
want to get your reaction to Andrew
Burnham there would you be pleased to
see him back in Westminster definitely
you know Andy's doing a brilliant job as
mayor of Greater Manchester and I think
what you see right across the country is
labor local Authority leaders labor
Mayors if you like showing what can be
done what can be done if you're in power
but Andy is a great talent for our party
and he can serve Us in multiple ways
okay right let's talk about your uh
policy you're announcing today a labor
government would deliver Net Zero for
electricity by 2030 to talk to us about
a zero carbon power system this is a
world leading commitment that we are
making and why we do it Sophie it will
make a difference in a number of ways
first of all it will cut people's energy
bills because let's be clear about this
the only way to get out of this fossil
fuels crisis the only way to cut bills
is green energy green energy is
currently nine times cheaper than gas
that's Renewables like wind and solar
they're nine times cheaper than gas so
it will save 93 billion pounds of bills
over the coming years it will give us
energy security we won't be relying on
Putin's gas for example homegrown
renewable and nuclear power thirdly
it'll create jobs half a million jobs
for our country and it puts us in the
Forefront of the fight against the
climate crisis so it's the kind of
radical action we need and crucially and
this is a contrast with last Friday it
is about building an economy that works
for the many right across our country
not about building an economy which is
for a few at the top of our society you
say it's radical at the same time the
government has also committed to Net
Zero electricity by 2035 it's just five
years earlier well it's fine well just
five years I mean five years is a long
time we're in a decisive moment and look
people so how much will it cost to do it
five years earlier then well here's the
thing the vast majority of this will
come not from the taxpayer but will come
from private investment you see private
investors are lining up to go for wind
energy and so energy but but they can't
because government blocks them on
onshore wind blocks them on solar and
doesn't make the Investments we need
what will the cost be just explain the
the well so we've made a pledge of a 28
billion pounds each and every year a a
green Prosperity plan pledge we think
this will cost around 2 billion a year
to make this happen so a small
proportion of that pledge and it is the
right thing to do for the country and
crucially you know if I'd be on your
program 10 years ago your program wasn't
on 10 years ago if I'd if I'd been on 10
years ago I would have said look green
is the ethical choice and it's it's the
right thing to do for the long term it's
the ethical choice and the economic
choice now now it's such a contrast with
the government because they say well the
answer is fracking and all these things
which will not make any difference to
bills and aren't safe you talk about
affordability and obviously everyone I
think or the vast majority of people
would accept that green energy and is
and Renewables is a key part to
affordability but at the same time if
your focus was just on affordability
you'd be looking at everything wouldn't
you you'd be looking at Green Renewables
yes you would but you'd also be looking
at North Sea oil and gas you'd also be
looking at fracking too because don't
you just need to look at the no you
wouldn't it's really important to
explain this to people look gas is sold
on a global market the price we pay for
North Sea gas or Frac gas if that ever
happens is exactly the same as we pay
for imported gas don't take much just a
second don't take my word for it
quasi-quarting the chancellor said it
will make no difference to price that
it's it's an illusion Supply overall
Global Supply and so that is whoever is
producing oil and gas who isn't who that
is going to benefit isn't it no I mean
look we've got to use the North Sea
we're going to be carry on using the
little C but if what you're asking me is
is fracking or some dash for gas in the
north C going to be the answer it is not
going to be the answer but it won't
bring down prices and this is the key
thing and on fracking I've got to say
Sophie I mean you know it's obviously
been slightly lost because of the
appalling budget we had on uh Friday
from quasi-cotting but the idea that the
government that promised in the 2019
general election not to restart fracking
unless it was safe now he's going to do
so and what is their excuse what they
say not that they found out it's safe
but that a bit more risk is a price
worth paying for people across our
country it just says it all about this
government they stand up for the fossil
fuel companies they don't stand up for
the British people so you say that you
want to spend 28 billion pounds a year
on the kind of green energy deal
um at a time when borrowing it is at the
levels that it is partly of course
because of uh government policy but
let's be frank mainly uh because of what
we've seen with inflation energy bills
and so on as well we know that you would
also like to freeze uh bills is spending
28 billion pounds a year a sensible
thing to do absolutely it is and I'll
tell you why it is and you see it with
the policy I'm announcing today that the
whole reason we're making this
investment is we get a return and what
you're going to be hearing from labor
this week is not just today's plan on a
2030 zero carbon power our world leading
plan but you're going to be hearing a
series of policies from me from Rachel
Reeves from Kirsten about how making
those those investments will create the
jobs across our country that we need get
us ahead in the global race you see the
difference between us and the government
is not whether we need growth yes
they've had an appalling growth record
I'm fine I'm glad they're finally
admitting it the question is how do you
create that growth they say tax cuts for
some people at the top for Millionaires
and bankers is going to create the
growth the wealth will trickle down to
everybody else or we know that's being
tried in the past and totally failed we
say something different
you build you build the economy from the
ground up by making these Investments
and today is Phase One the first
building block at the same time they
look the the evidence on tax cuts is
mixed and greatest mix it's not mixed
well if you look at you know Reagan for
example they would point to in the
states
the international monetary fund right
hardly a kind of group of kind of Looney
lefties the international monetary fund
says that actually if you look
increasing the incomes of the top share
of the top part of our society does not
lead to higher growth quite the opposite
okay so would a labor government reverse
the 45p account well look we've said
we're against it we said it's the wrong
thing to do let me just tell you why
it's the wrong thing to do I'm giving it
giving a 50 giving a 50 000 pound tax
cut to millionaires in our country is
not the right answer so now policy just
let me answer the question I think I'll
I'll you'll be pleased uh
Kirsten and Rachel Reeve set out tax
policy but and Q will be saying more
about this quite shortly but let me be
clear we're going to be consistent in
our election Manifesto with our
opposition to the 45p tax cuts we think
it's the wrong thing to do for the
country understood how about the 19p uh
cut the cut from 20p to 19. no we don't
think that should be reversed because
you know remember that when we're
talking about this basic rate cut I mean
that's people start paying that at 12
and a half thousand so you disagree with
Andy Burnham then well I don't think we
should reverse that tax cut look the
point is the government has raised taxes
on ordinary families by massive amounts
The Institute fiscal study says that
even with that tax cut 20 to 19 ordinary
families will still be paying more in
taxes in fact everyone up to 155 000
pounds we're paying more tax than at the
start of the pond so we don't we won't
be reversing that now okay understood
now if you ask Liz truss and Kumasi
quite to sum up in a word what their
government was all about a word yes we
know well I know I can imagine what your
word might be but their word would be
growth right what would be your word to
sum up what this labor government I
won't give you hope but look it says
something like account for the backdrop
a fairer Greener future and that is what
we're about you know fairness because we
don't think that as you look at the
problems our country faces that the
answer is lifting the bank bonus cap or
tax cuts for millionaires cost of living
crisis the NHS so Farah Greener and the
two go together and they produce not
only fairness but prosperity for our
country do you think that
there is a I guess some would say that
labor hasn't been bold enough going
forward on setting out what you would do
if you're in government on strikes for
example are you for against strikes do
you think that do you think that there
is a need for labor to be a little bit
more radical well look I think I think
you know I I was sort of leader of the
opposition so I've got some I've got
some previous on this you know it's
there's a sort of there's a kind of
cycle to these things that you know at
the beginning of the parliament you'll
you tend to be less specific more
thematic I think what you're seeing from
labor this week and what you're going to
see in the coming days and the first
thing today you know this is a bold plan
we're announcing I mean you know no
other country no other major country in
the world has said what we are saying
today that by by 2030 we'll have a zero
carbon power system I mean that is a big
deal and you're going to be seeing a lot
more of that in the days to come we'll
be seeing a lot more of kirst armor as
well as someone that has been described
as boring According to some Anonymous
briefings um can you I'm sure I was
described as that you're probably not
anonymously either can you tell us
something surprising about kirst armor
something surprising
you know actually I think what you see
with kirst armor is what you get and
actually I think the British people want
that and what is that
dependability decency Integrity somebody
who's going to do the right thing for
the country and you know we had the
years of Boris Johnson we had somebody
who you know broke the rules broke the
law did all the did all those things
anymore no we're not but I think people
want someone to DEC Integrity who knows
where he came from and knows what he's
in politics for look he looks at this
country and sees deep Injustice and he
says we're going to change this economy
we're going to change this country and
you're going to be hearing a lot more of
that from him this week you mentioned
that you've been at Labor lead yeah I
remember
any advice on how to cope with I guess
some of the pressures of being leader I
think I sort of think he doesn't need my
advice I think the only thing I'd say is
and it goes to your the question you
just asked me which is
don't pretend to be something you're not
and that and that's what's been very
good about kids leadership do you think
you did that a bit more uh no I mean I
think probably what what I mean sort of
video but it's a sort of ancient history
but you know in a way I said I wish I'd
been Bolder as labor leader maybe I felt
too much of the weight of the the office
you know too felt too constrained but I
think you know I think Big Ideas are our
friend in politics I think I think
people in the country and remember it's
about people in the country they you
know I I lost election 2015. since then
we've had the brexit referendum we've
had all kinds of things that have
happened in our country I think all of
them show one thing though so many
people say the economy the country
doesn't work for me what are you going
to do to make life better for me what
are you going to do to change things for
me and I think that's where Labor's
Focus needs to be do you think he's got
a better chance of winning an election
than you did yes yes definitely
um and look I think the thing about Kia
is that people can see him as a credible
prime minister uh and I think they're
going to be seeing this week the ideas
the things he cares about that he wants
to do if he was to win that election
okay thanks very much
now on Friday of course the chancellor
announced new legislation to require
unions to put pay offers to staff before
calling strikes well quite also wants
so-called minimum service levels to stop
strikes shutting down transport networks
as well now unions as you might expect
uh condemned the move as more strikes
are announced on the rail network with a
threat of action across the economy and
public services as well now the UK's
biggest Union is Unison with 1.3 million
members that work in public services and
I'm delighted to say the general
secretary Christina mcaney is with us
now thank you very much for being uh
with us this morning well it wasn't a
mini Budget on Friday was it it was a
mega budget the biggest tax cuts for
half a century
um what impact do you think that might
have on public services well as ever
they'll be the ones that are expected to
pay for this
um I mean the irony is during austerity
years when we had Cameron and um
uh George Osborne selling this everyone
was in it together and uh you know we
had to cut back and public sector Works
had to take a pay for these and now it's
spent
and again I'm pretty certain it'll be
public sector workers and public
services that will actually end up
paying for this because they'll they've
already announced they want big reforms
they want to um they're telling us to
exercise peer restraint and it seems
under the this government public
services are just no and not a priority
at all and now Unison is balloting it's
a NHS workers over strike action so we
could see you know nurses going on
strike midwives going on strike
now a lot of our viewers might be a bit
worried about what that means right you
know because you can't choose the timing
of when to have a straight you can't use
when to have a baby when I can't delay
it till after strike action
isn't patient safety going to be a bit
at risk here well patient safety is
always Paramount we have struck we're
having strikes before we had the strike
in 2014 in England England and Wales and
uh we will always put in minimum to that
safe Staffing levels uh the interesting
thing is when uh relationship is going
to bring in minimum Staffing levels
we've been calling for that for years in
the NHS because we don't have it and
what our members uh what the members are
telling me you know so paramedics or
nurses or cleaners in hospitals are
saying things like the service is so
badly run down it's on its knees there's
not enough staff and actually taking
strike action they don't think will make
it any worse but what it might help do
is one get them more money when they're
totally struggling but to actually draw
attention to the fact that the
government has no proper plan or
strategy for dealing with some of their
major and essential Public Services I
guess what I don't understand is if
Staffing is so stretched in the NHS and
under so much pressure then surely
strike action is going to make things
worse how could it not well
strike action has to be effective and by
that it must have an impact in any
sector but certainly where it's about
people's life and safety there will
always be a life in line policy we will
always agree with local employers
certain levels of cover but it does mean
other things won't get done it will have
an impact without a doubt what kind of
impact could it have well sometimes they
might have to cancel operations
um
certain clinics won't open but essential
life-saving things you know in a e
departments and as you see in maternity
departments will still continue because
everybody knows you can't choose when
you're going to have a baby so you won't
get midways walking off a ward when
there's women in labor that just won't
happen but we could have more delayed
operations canceled operations yes yes
that could happen understood
um so you're also you are launching
legal action I think I might say against
the government's trying to stop the use
of agency workers to cover uh struggling
nurses is that correct yeah so just
explain so the government's brought in
late or started legislation to bring in
to allow employers to bring in agency
workers when basically a straight
breaker so in we have legislation
currently in this country and indeed
most of Europe which says you can't do
that and the government in this wisdom
on the lack of has decided they're going
to change that now not only are we
concerned about it the organizations
that represent agency workers are
concerned about her isn't that about
ensuring patient safety well maybe
there's anything you do have enough
people to look after people in hospitals
if it's necessary there's 140 000
vacancies in the NHS at the moment that
aren't the agency workers out there to
come and do it and if there are people
who have chosen to you know give their
services through an agency it's because
they get paid so much more more than you
would if they're employed by the NHS and
that's a problem for the country as a
whole and you do I mean this thing about
removing the cap and bankers bonuses
because they're losing good people where
is the evidence for that or is this just
dinner party talk where the friends say
oh it's Dreadful I'm going to have to go
to Hong Kong to get more money I can
actually provide hard evidence of 140
000 vacancies in the NHS 160 000
vacancies in the Care Service why don't
the government do something about that
we're seeing uh strikes um being called
or ballasted on across so many
Industries with inflation high and
people feeling their wages aren't
keeping up do you think we're getting
close to a general strike
well
we're certainly getting close to a
well-coordinated strike across different
sectors now in the past is that a
general strike no there's a legal
definition of a general strike as far as
I'm aware which is it's predominantly a
political act and there's very strong
tough legislation in this country that
makes that virtually impossible so it's
not impossible but it's not you know we
probably wouldn't call it a general
strike but what you would call it is a
strike across a whole range of sectors
at the same time which is not the same
as a general strike and it sounds a lot
of people might say look it's a
coordinator strike across different
sectors and unions it is kind of a
general strike well if I was to see
we're calling a general street my
Union's funds would be sequestered any
of the members who took part in what's
called a political strike would lose any
protection from dismissal they would
just be sacked so if you don't call it a
general strike then well it's not a bit
not calling it what we're doing isn't
going through legal process to bring our
members out safely and legally and give
them the protection we have the toughest
industrial relations legislation in this
country you have to jump through about
10 12 herbs just to be able to bring
people out on legal strikes and that's
why this sort of demonizing of of
workers who are already on strike is so
unfair because this is oh they're taking
part in legal disputes and legal strikes
and that take part in unlawful strikes
would you like to see a tougher line
from labor on this
um
you know to be quite honest I don't
think it makes a difference whether
laborer our own picket lines are not
labor is there
to I think hopefully work with us and I
think if there was a labor government in
place I would hope that we wouldn't be
just about to ballot 400 000 NHS workers
by the end of this year and we talked
that we've talked to us I wrote to Liz
twist let's trust the day she got
elected and congratulated her and said
we'd be happy to work with her but they
obviously see unions as part of the
problem and actually strikes are a
symptom of problems they're not the
cause of the problems and we're willing
to work with them pretty certain Francis
O'Grady from the General Secretary of
the TUC would be well into work with her
but we're getting nothing back from this
government other than you getting much
back from labor yeah yeah and we want
Western on you know new policies that
are coming forward we don't get
everything we want because you know they
want to govern the country for everyone
not just for trade unions and therefore
we won't get everything that we want but
we can certainly try and influence them
and work with them to get to get changes
in that actually benefit working people
thanks very much for being on the
program today good to talk to you thank
you
now our next guest Peter mandelson was
alongside Tony Blair and Gordon Brown
one of the architects of new labor which
was of course one of the most
electorally successful eraser of well
any part of his party in particular he
famous the one said he was intensely
relaxed about people getting Filthy Rich
although he did sort of walk it back
slightly years later well I'm very uh
looking forward to speaking to him to
try and find out about how he thinks
labor should react to Friday's tax cuts
and does he think costama is ready to be
prime minister good to have you on the
program this morning at Mr mandelson
um
I'm afraid you didn't uh complete my
quote
uh I talked about it's fine for people
to become rich as long as they pay their
taxes a rather important qualification
which you left out
absolutely I completely uh take your
point uh on that um are you relaxed
about the bankers bonus cat then just
quickly before we start the rest of the
interview
I don't really have strong views on the
bankers bonus cap either way frankly I
don't think it's a priority uh for us in
getting the economy growing again I mean
what I feel about the Chancellor's
package on Friday
is that it will take some time to see uh
how Reckless a gamble it may well turn
out to be through higher inflation
higher higher borrowing costs for
companies higher interest rates for
mortgage holders
um so let's see how this uh pans out but
I do believe that what Labor's got to do
is not concentrate on all the noise
surrounding uh what is trusted and
quasi-quarten are doing they've got to
concentrate on their own agenda setting
out their own plan for growth
and I'm very pleased that they've
started to do that at the at the
conference in Liverpool today
growth because
he made a speech saying that labor
should focus on raising the UK's
long-term growth rate it feels since she
made that speech that Liz truss has done
everything she can to try and occupy
that space do you think I guess Labor's
been a bit slow at the blocks on this
I don't think this trust is doing that I
think she is certainly taking the
country off in a radical Direction but I
don't think it's the right direction
because at the same time as these
measures that we heard from heard about
on Friday
the government is also closing down all
the Machinery relating to the
development and exploitation of
Britain's brilliant Science and
Technology based in this country you
know she's closed down the cabinet
committee the National Machinery for
bringing government and business
together to exploit uh the new
technologies she's closed down the
office of Science and Technology
strategy in the cabinet office this is
the wrong thing to do what we've got to
do is as Ed miliband was saying before
is invest very heavily and primarily
through private sector investment in the
technology-based new Industries and
markets and employment that are emerging
now in our economy and that private
investment depends on economic stability
regulatory certainty
cheap borrowing costs but also a very
strong partnership between government
and business and I'm glad that the
shadow business secretary Johnny
Reynolds is publishing a document
tomorrow precisely on that subject how
Government Can Work hand in hand with
the private sector to bring about that
much needed investment in the whole
Spate of technology-based new industries
that are emerging at this heart of which
is the green energy transition
you're talking about the talking about
the green energy transition and you've
said that you know Labor's commitment to
spending 28 billion pounds for 10 years
on climate change and you were talking
about in this speech saying just
announcing a massive spend and a big
policy goal does not in itself deliver
economic growth do you still have those
concerns or do you think you're getting
a bit more meat on the bone now oh we're
getting much more meat on the bone I
mean look
the the whole point is this Sophie if I
can just make it very simply and clearly
government and business public
investment and private investment
together
needs to invest in these new
technology-based Industries and markets
that are emerging not just from the
green transition but the whole diffusion
of digital technology and the emerging
critical Technologies like artificial
intelligence and the use of of data
across the economy in society but here's
the point we've got to translate those
great transitions that are taking place
into the creation of UK industry
uk-based Supply chains and uk-based
employment rather than seeing that
massive expenditure leaking out of our
economy and going off to benefit our
neighboring economies and I'm very
pleased that
the plans that are going to be set out
this week both by Rachel Reeves Ed
miliband and Johnny Reynolds again to
set out that industrial policy which
needs to support this very large-scale
uh public and private investment
now you of course are parts of the most
all
millions of election at six hours the
famous of course 1997 Landslide under
Tony Blair and you've been pretty
critical of where Labor's been since you
said that labor needs a complete break
from the last 10 years of failure under
Ed miliband and Jeremy corbyn also
describing at miliband this was in 2021
as a flop and a complete failure has
that complete break happened
I don't remember describing Ed Miller
Band in that way but I'm sure your
researchers will be able to furnish you
uh with the facts look here's the point
about Friday and it offers both an
opportunity and a challenge for labor
the opportunity is that in taking
tearing off in the direction they've
chosen the conservatives are forfeiting
their reputation for sound money and
fiscal discipline that's been a very
hard one electoral weapon that they've
created and deployed since Mrs
Thatcher's uh time and they've thrown
that away in the measures they announced
on Friday but here's the challenge for
labor
in in responding to what Liz truss is
doing is taking the conservative party
uh it back into its own sort of
ideological right-wing comfort zone as
we saw them doing uh on Friday Labor's
response should not be to retreat into
its own uh Comfort uh zone of tax and
spend and big state and the policies
that we associate with Jeremy corbyn you
know the public have got to know and
they've got to be reminded every day
from here to Bolding day that Jeremy
corbyn and his supporters and all they
stood for are behind us and that it's
now completely safe to vote for labor
again that we've got sensible middle
Crown practical affordable policies
which are going to bring about that
economic transformation and that
structural change in our economy that we
need in order to sustain economic growth
in the long term
do you think labor would now win the
next election
I I do actually believe that what we are
seeing emerging in the country is a sort
of shift in public opinion
um I think we are seeing a potential uh
sea change in attitudes in the public
about what the public wants and what the
public won't put up with but but here's
the point Liz trusts in effect and the
conservatives in their effect
are taking their own policy Direction
off the center ground the middle ground
or British politics now that creates an
opportunity for labor to occupy that uh
Center ground the that's where the
swathe of Voters exist in the country
who are going to determine the outcome
of the next election and they are
focused both on economic competence
and fairness and social justice those
are two sides of the coin the policy
coin the political coin that the broad
mass of Voters right across the center
ground are British politics are focused
on that's what they want to vote for and
that's what labor needs to offer
thank you we are out of time but just
quickly um do you speak much to kirst
armor offer him any advice
I I do speak to him from uh time to time
yes and members of his team but I don't
do for him and for them what I did for
uh Tony Blair and Gordon Brown and
before them uh Neil kinnick but when
they want any help you know my door my
phone's uh there for them to to call but
you know they they've chosen their calls
they want to do their own thing I
perfectly well understand that and
actually I strongly support the course
uh they're taking and I support Kia
stalma because I think he's a
hard-working public spirited uh
patriotic uh leader for this country uh
the Prime Minister that I think
overwhelmingly now the part the public
are moving towards and deciding that
they want to see in number 10.
okay thank you very much uh indeed
Mendelson thank you
now the r t Union is leaving leading a
wave of strikes across the railway
Network the biggest for decades but
General Secretary Mick Lynch met with
the new transport secretary and Marie
trevelyn recently and said it was a good
start and a pleasant meeting so is a
fool in the air could a deal be on the
cast let's try and find out
um is a deal on the cards or a strike
action inevitable well there's no deal
on the table on the strike action we've
got down over the next two weeks we'll
go ahead as far as we know what we need
to see from the new secretary of state
is is the ability to unblock the
problems in the in the dispute her
predecessor seems to be putting
obstacles in the way of everyone
including the employers by shackling
them to a mandate that was impossible to
deliver they were putting down issues
that we could never accept and the other
trade unions can never accept so I've
asked the new secretary of state and it
was it was a good meeting and a positive
attitude a good will to try and unthaw
this situation we need to get the thing
out of deep freeze and get it on the
table so we can work through the problem
so I've asked her to be a facilitator
for that and I hope she can do it but
I'll have to see whether there's any
proof in that put in over the next few
weeks but you are a bit optimistic then
it does seem like you've got quite
different views so far to be invited to
a meeting than be uh harangued all over
the media which is what we were getting
I was going into certain Studios saying
look let's try and get a deal if you
want to talk to us you can and he was
just slagging us off threatening us with
more and more anti-trade Union laws
calling me a dinosaur and a baron and
all this kind of nonsense and if
somebody wants to meet you and shake
your hand that's a positive start it's a
better way to conduct business than than
just slagging each other off and that's
not what I'm into and I hope that she's
not either at the same time we have seen
tightening of strike laws haven't we on
Friday uh what do you make of that well
they're not just strike laws they're
they're an attack on civil liberties and
human rights so they're trying to make
it impossible for trade unions to exist
in this country and they're trying to
make it impossible in fact to for the
people of this country to campaign
against poverty which is what many of
them are changing if there is no trade
Union freedom and it's impossible to
conduct lawful industrial action people
will have to go another way they'll have
to think of other means of doing it
they're trying to regulate unions and
they've said they're going to cut red
tape the only people that are going to
be subject to stringent regulation are
the trade unions and they want to
regulate the relationship between the
union and its members that's not
acceptable people will always regret
further oppression of Trade union rights
because we won't be able to protest
we've got a new police bill that's going
to stop us protesting on the streets and
we're going to have a set of Trade union
laws that attempt to stop us having a
balanced equation in the workplace and
that's not acceptable you say that if it
in your words becomes impossible to
strike people will find other means what
what do you mean what if people can't
take lawful industrial action they're
less to take unlawful industrial action
and we're fast get into a situation
where we're going to have the laws that
are as oppressive as those that exist in
Russia and China and back in Poland
before solidaris came along and took
unlawful industrial action in that
environment to break free of the
oppression of the old Soviet Bloc and
the Communist Regime over there what
specifically just just to come in
because obviously it's quite a big
statement to say that the laws are as
oppressive as those in Russia and around
the world
they're going to make it impossible for
us to have lawful ballots they're going
to make it impossible through let's just
explain what well because they're going
to raise the thresholds to a level where
it will be very difficult 50 turnouts
and 50 of the of the whole population in
the ballot uh to get to get a yes vote
if if we brought those in into local
councils for instance or indeed in
Parliament most of the people that
currently serve on local councils
wouldn't be councilors if we brought
those into Parliament most of the people
in Parliament do not receive 50 of the
vote in parliamentary elections they
won't allow us to do electronic voting
it all has to be done by the Royal Mail
by postal voting but they won't allow us
to use any modern techniques they want
to fine us for any mistakes we make
during ballots that we could finish
trade unions and they want us to give
four weeks notice which will make
effective industrial action very
difficult to carry out and they want us
to do this continual round of referenda
uh based on every single offer or every
discussion that we have of an employer
which allows us running around like
spinning tops if you've been employed
offers me 1.95 one week and the next
week offers me 1.96 uh cars equating
saying I'd like to do a referendum every
time that somebody scratches their nose
it's a ridiculous situation and it's
going to make it impossible for us to
operate we speak to the Unison General
Secretary a bit earlier on the program
and she was saying that look you know
the a technical general strike is
unlikely to happen but yes there is
coordinated action
for many people that is basically a
general strike
well you need to make their power
effective and we don't at the end of the
day is negotiations fail we've got
intransigent employers and many
Employers in this country are making
super profits the rich are getting
richer than they've ever been so unions
are organizing together that would be
fair well we talked to each other will
you be silly for unions not good to
coordinate their forces and so we're
taking action alongside the postal
workers next week alongside the hours
left Union and if other people want to
join in a wave of response and
resistance to what's going on where the
rich are being made richer all of the
time and we've seen that in the budget
on Friday where the people everybody
who's under 155 000 in salary will be
poorer and every Everybody above that
salary will be richer well we've got to
be able to rebalance our society and our
economy so it does sound like we'll be
seeing coordinated action strike action
if we cannot get settlements we'll have
to coordinate our actions and what do
you make of Labor's response
well I want to see labor win I want
labor to win the next election I want
kirst armor to be our next prime
minister that's what I want but I think
in order to do that he's got to show
that he empathizes and sympathize of
what working people are going through
they're really struggling people are
scared that they're going to lose their
homes never mind to eat them people are
going to face landlords that are pushing
up pushing up rents and banks that are
pushing up mortgage rates that's on top
of the utility bills crisis and the
price of of living he's got to show that
he identifies with what we're going
through has he shown that yet I haven't
seen it uh if I could see it I'd be
delighted so I'm hoping this week that
we can all come away saying look Kia
storm was on our side we can put our
shoulder to his wheel to get him elected
and he's putting his shoulder to work in
people's will to help them in their
everyday problems but I want to see a
set of values I don't mind about
detailed policy that's to come but I
want him to show that he's got the
values that identify with the men and
women in this country that are really
struggling are frightened of what's in
front of them so do you think he should
be on a picket line then I'm not worried
about whether he's on a picket line or
not I don't expect him to be there but I
want him to identify with our causes and
the issues that we Face how does he do
that then I think he sets out a program
some some uh Charters some some values
that say we've got a housing crisis in
this country we've got an energy price
uh problem in this country we've got a
wages problem and he needs to say that
I'm I'm on your side and when we get
into Power we're going to bring in a set
of measures regulations and laws that
rebalance the way that working people
are treated in this country and gives
them a voice in the workplace and in
society do you ever speak to him I spoke
to him over the piano crisis and he was
really good he was really on our side I
don't expect him to do what I tell him
to do I don't think well the world works
like that I come up to the labor
conference to try and influence and talk
to friends talk to people that don't
like me and there are plenty of them as
well so you know we're here to influence
and try to help in some ways I'm hoping
that he can show that he's sympathetic
to what we're going through Railway
workers are really struggling and
millions of other workers are really
struggling we've got the personal
workers we've got the dockers on strike
right now in Liverpool he can show that
he's on their side and sympathizes with
what they do that doesn't mean he has to
Wade directly into each and every
dispute but he's got a show he's on the
side of the workers because after all
this is a labor party the name's on the
tin and he's got to show that he's a
friend of every worker in this country
okay thank you very much on the program
to say Nick Lynch at that of the rnt
and now it can often feel like there's a
bit of Disconnect between Westminster
and what's actually going on in people's
lives around the country so each week on
the program we're trying to speak to
people from across the United Kingdom
and really talk about the challenges
that they're facing being on the cost of
living and energy crisis all the NHS
perhaps housing crime and more as well
too now here in Liverpool we are trying
to look a bit at the NHS we were
speaking about it earlier in the program
but just 10 days ago bosses at the Royal
Liverpool Hospital issued a full
capacity warning staff in a letter that
there was no space in resuscitation
areas and we can speak now to NHS staff
nurse Mark Anthony and here his story I
thank you very much for uh being with us
it's good to have you on the program
today I mean look we see the statistics
on the NHS waiting times ambulance
delays proponed appointments but I guess
I'm interested to hear The Human Side
what is it like to work on the in the
NHS at the minute
it's absolutely terrible for staff
working in NHS at the moment they're
we're chronically understaffed uh staff
cannot even give the basic care for
patients then sometimes that you get
staff
getting in trouble because they've not
been able to give medication on time or
to get end up getting some performance
plans or disciplines and it's not their
fault at all this is the fault of the
government the government has let the
nursing down
terribly over the past 10 years we're
vastly underpaid and the Staffing is
absolutely so bad now that I fear for
patient safety I really do and and I
think I think that unless we have no
choice now of the Royal College of
Nursing to ballot for strike action
we're not doing this doing this um for
our own uh selfish names or anything
like that we will grow grossly underpaid
uh nurses are leaving in their droves of
20 000 left this year and now we end up
in a situation where patients are so
much at risk now that that we have to do
we have to do things like this this
government is not listening and it never
was going to listen and we always but
we've tried very very hard to negotiate
and we're not getting anywhere
um just I wanted to hear a bit about
what it's like on the actual uh Wards
you know you were talking about the
pressure that nurses are under
um patient safety is being put at risk
um what what kind of things do you mean
is it like people have been given the
wrong medication because there's a rash
or what is it like
what it is is that the girls are so
understaffed that you can actually get
situations where sometimes patients on
at times maybe not giving the medication
in time sometimes there's situations
where where where the patients are put
at risk because because they could have
health and safety issues about Falls and
things like that that on the world
there's also also situations where just
the basic care sometimes you get some
patience unfortunately which is which is
tragic to say this that sometimes can be
sat in faces and nurses can't get to
them in times where they'll go to try to
and in just a basic curve of even just
trying to trying to give them food and
things like that it's getting so bad now
that that that that that that that's
willing it I've never known it as bad as
this because I've been nursing 35 years
and now I I know it's a no from the
stories that I hear from my colleagues I
think that that this this is just a dire
situation and and it's only going to get
worse
and you've been a nurse for 35 years so
you're still a nurse you're also a
member of the Royal College of Nursing
Union is this the worst that you've ever
seen it
it is definitely the worst ever I've
ever seen it
um and the true tragedy that was
happening now this is actually becoming
the norm
if this carries on
um
the NHS is just going to lose its value
as to what used to be I mean I'm proud
to be a nurse I'm proud to uh I joined
it as a vocation I joined it to
represent to to want to care for people
and now it's not coming that way you
just come under shifts and you're
totally stressed out you're totally yeah
and you know that's going to be a really
hard shift that they're moving staff
from one world to the other from One
hospital to the other it's like
shuffling the pack because it goes a
good situation this the the the Staffing
levels to us towards a number of
patients it can be can be drastic it's
something you can get two stuff and you
get 20 odd to 30 patients on on a Ward
and and that is just just not good
enough is absolutely it's dangerous it
is and and something has to be done and
if they don't don't pay nurses the
proper pay that they should be getting
and remember we've been taking a pay cut
over the past 10 years and and we're
constantly trying to battle for this
division because if you don't pay nurses
the proper paid a nurse is going to
continue to leave the service not
wanting to do that they have no choice
really we didn't join nursing so we do
it poor we want we join using to want to
take care of patients who want to want
to do be responsible for doing that and
we would love it we love our job but not
Network now we get we're pushed so much
now that we have no choice now but to
come out fighting
okay thank you very much indeed really
interesting as always you know to hear
the stories from people on the front
line going to keep trying to do it on
the program Mark Anthony there a staff
nurse and member of the Royal College of
Nursing
oh that is it for this week's at Sophie
Ridge on Sunday here at Liverpool uh
conference in a moment after the break
by our Deputy political editor at Sam
coats plus two labor and please will be
here as well to talk about where they
hope that their party goes over the next
couple of years thanks for joining us
this Sunday morning
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hello welcome to Liverpool where we are
at the labor party conference this is
Sophie Ridge on Sunday the take where we
digest what we've just heard in the last
hour but also to be honest look it's a
special special program for us we're in
Liverpool we want to be finding out all
about what labor is going to be doing
over the next few days and I'm delighted
to say we are joined live here by our
Deputy uh Sam coats but we've also got
two at Labor MPS to talk to as well uh
the MP for War Thunder crusi and the
stratum Bell Riviera Andy thank you very
much for being out with us this morning
uh right Sam let's start off with you
first uh what has labor got to do at
this conference well I think for good
reason there are people around kirstama
saying that really this is the most
important moment since he became labor
leader a couple of years ago because it
I think if we're being honest Sophie
what we haven't seen over the last 12
months for completely understandable
reasons is kirstema actually intruding
massively into our national story and
that's because we've had a huge tour
recycled drama you know we've talked for
months upon months of about Boris
Johnson and parties Ukraine came along
and then you have the leadership contest
at the election of this trust and uh
that big change in Direction last Friday
now all of that and I think they would
acknowledge this around here so let's
squeeze the amount of space that he's
had to kind of really project himself on
the British public so the main job this
week I think is to catch everybody's
attention to actually put out that
alternative to to deal with that slight
criticism that there's been a little bit
under the surface that he spends all his
time niggling and criticizing and
opposing but doesn't set out a great big
bold vision and have you got any idea
whether that's going to happen or not
I've got a bit of policy this morning Ed
miliban was talking about it with the
commitment to Net Zero for electricity
by 20 30 five years faster than the
government was saying we've heard this
morning that labor would reinstate the
45p rate of tax but would not reverse
the 20p to 19p income tax so are we
getting assigned that they're being bold
so with what we saw on Friday from Liz
trust in the new Chancellor aquatic
party they effectively turned political
Orthodoxy Tory Orthodoxy on its head
with that set of uh very large uh
controversial announcements in order to
prop up they think uh growth so one of
the things that Kirsten has started to
have to do this morning is on to the
questions that they leave and as you say
this morning that we now know that labor
would reverse in office that decision to
get rid of the highest rate attacks of
people over 150 000 pounds kirstan was
made that absolutely clear if he gets
into government as labor government they
would reinstate a high level of tax
would be loading over 150 000 pounds
interestingly it looks like they would
keep the decision to cut the basic rate
of tax from 20p to 19p and but so I
think it's a sort of bigger challenge
here is that Kirsten can't just run
around this conference being chased by
Liz truss's essay questions the the
question is whether or not his vision is
big enough and bold enough eye-catching
up an exciting off now I think we've had
a bit of a hint about what that vision
is going to center around it's the one
that Ed miliband was talking to about
it's about green jobs and that Net Zero
uh carpet Target for power for 2030. now
the question I think is does that uh
engage and does It capture the
imagination of people that's a Target
it's got some detail attached about
doubling of solar onshore wind but is
that a match in the imagination of the
country uh something that can match the
scale of the stuff that we saw on Friday
because I think his time has got to make
sure that he doesn't end up just
answering those questions and ending up
having a bit of a fight with a left we
did that at last year's labor conference
he he had a bit of a battle with the
left he won that battle uh but he hasn't
got the political time and space to do
that again you heard Andy Byrne niggling
around at the side I think it massively
matters Mandy Burnham isn't an MP he's
not really going for the leadership yet
but he's got to make sure that the
headline's on about that but about what
he wants to talk about and that that cut
through it is exciting enough what's the
forward slogan at the end of this week
that defines Labor's Economic Policy I
don't know yet I don't know yet whether
they're even gonna have one well let's
uh put some of those questions Samuel to
our MP guests as well really interesting
as always to hear your thoughts Sam
um I think it's a good point isn't it um
Ed miliband can't just fall into the
Trap of answering the essay questions
that Liz trust has set and what do you
want to see from a billabander at this
conference spell
I'll need another coffee this morning
obviously
a long way to go right I'm actually I
think we need to see a Clear Vision I'm
really worried that people keep saying
they don't know what we stand for and
you know there's some I don't think
we're gonna have an election anytime
soon
um people are preparing for one but even
if people aren't preparing for even if
it's not going to happen anytime soon we
need to be clear we need to be clear for
a long period of time because if one was
to just be called we'd only have a short
period of time to convince people so
everyone needs to know now what we stand
for what we're going to do how we're
going to be different it's not good
enough to just say we're not the Tories
vote for us do you know what labor
stands for I know what labor was founded
on and I know what I believe we should
stand for but I'm not completely clear
at this moment what our plans are moving
forward I'm sure they're in play
um I don't think anybody is is
ridiculous enough not to be in play but
I just think it needs to be laid out
fearlessly and you know some people
won't like it but it's not for the
people that won't like it we need to
convince those that aren't that usually
vote labor we need to convince those
people that we know that we can bring
along so we shouldn't show Fear just
because we may have the right wing press
coming up against us or other people
making certain comments who are
traditionally told me voters we need to
go out and secure our base
do you agree with that I have been
really surprised by the people in my
community you're not particularly
political who are genuinely angry about
Friday genuinely angry that in a cost of
living crisis it's Bankers incomes that
this government is really concerned
about and are saying this has to stop so
I think what I agree with with bell
about is that now is not the time to
play it safe and showing people that
there is another way because the thing I
really worry about in politics people
somehow think well you're all the same
what Friday showed is that we are
clearly not what Sunday onwards need to
show is what that difference is and I'm
standing here as the chair of the labor
movement for Europe so I'm here also
this conference to say how are we going
to do this incorporation because Liz
truss is shredding our relationships
around the world running up massive
bills is like she's putting the gas bill
on the mortgage Bill and saying these
are the people I care about the rest of
you you're on your own I know working in
corporation not just in our communities
but as a country we can achieve better
so you ask about what we want to see
actually I'm pleased to ask about Ed
miliband I think it's really fantastic
to talk about renewable energy that
makes me of sense to people actually
renewable energy is cheaper than fossil
fuel right now but being a country that
produces it is a really good way to run
the economy but what I know is that we
could do that more efficiently if we
work with our European counterparts
across the north Seas to do that so what
I want to see at conference is not just
a recognition of the issues but some of
the processes that will show the public
we've got a plan for action it's quite
interesting listening to a bell there
just saying that she's not completely
sure what labor stands for at the minute
that you believe that obviously those
discussions are going on but right now
she's unsure I mean if labor MPS are
saying that then I guess that is a bit
of a problem yeah and I and I think the
reason it's hard is because it is hard
because your options are uh limited what
Liz trusted on Friday was spend a huge
amount of money to coin somebody a long
time ago there's no money left and there
won't be if and when you end up with the
labor government but you are also very
clear as a party that you are going to
maintain physical discipline that you're
going to stick to those fiscal rules
that Rachel Reeds has has outlined so
the question for me really is and it's a
not one that can be answered this
morning but if you're going to stick to
the rules you're not going to have much
money left how are you going to be able
to promise for instance big increases in
public services funding education
funding topping up the NHS money for
social care if labor can't do that over
the next year or two years what kind of
election offer do you have because
that's a really tricky area if you keep
fiscal disciplines no money left what
are you going to say on public services
let's take that question head on this is
why it matters to have a properly
redisputed tax systems why it matters
cutting the 45 people because doing that
the money that that raises would pay for
Universal Child Care from six months why
does that matter because that's an
infrastructure investment in our economy
because right now there are lots of
families and women in particular who
cannot work cannot pay taxes because
they can't get decent child care and it
doesn't stack up for the so yes
absolutely you can have fiscal
discipline but it's the understanding of
why you invest in people investing in
Bankers doesn't generate growth in the
same way that investing in people does
and things like childcare help make you
do that so we've heard this morning from
Kirsten that he would reinstate the 45p
additional rate but he would not reverse
the cut at the uh the 1p cut to the
lower rate of income tax do you think
that's right well I think what we need
to be doing overall is showing people
the maths essentially showing people
that how it's going to work out in terms
of what we're standing for I think
you've laid out what we as a labor party
would generally say when it comes to
these things the issue is how we're
convincing people and things like that
may not uh necessarily convince people
you just need to be a bit clearer on how
it's going to work because somebody
always have an argument against and I
just worry that sometimes when we're
explaining these things people aren't
understanding them in the in the way
that we're putting on it and it makes it
seem as if we're spending a whole lot of
money and things are just going to go to
complete you know completeness but it's
not true do you think labor needs to be
more careful than the conservatives as
well because the responsibility
this is a government that is actively
putting hot money into pockets of
millionaires and borrowing to be able to
do that and in the way that they're
borrowing the pound is the technical
term tanking which means there's going
to be even more expensive for us I'm not
going to take any lectures and
quasiquatic about fiscal discipline but
I take Sam's challenge but it's about
how you use the money to get a better
return for your buck so absolutely your
Bell's right we've got to show people
why the maths stack up because we're
facing a completely Reckless Chancellor
what he's doing would make Margaret
Thatcher blush okay we know the money's
there essentially because they can give
it away
yes we just need to show people how
we're going to redistribute and I think
we need to be quite clever about that
because they've proven that the money is
there and and whenever we want to spend
it on public spending they keep going on
about how oh you know you're just you're
just running up up our debts but they're
boring boring boring in a way that is
actually unsustainable they're not using
it for people we need to take a break
and we'll have more from the two of you
more from Sam in a few moments time uh
to see them
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
part of it is we'll want to do it in the
first place and I think is because you
get to examine the theme and the the
environment in which you are making the
movie at that time Pinocchio
state-of-the-art animate probably the
Apex of Disney's animation utilizing the
new multi-plane uh camera in which all
these photographic animation effects are
possible for the first time in the
future well Bob is going to approach
every shot like that as well
but then you also have the Thematic
elements of telling the truth you know
listening to your conscience making the
right choice and this movie The Original
came out in 1941 we know what that year
was like this movie is coming out in
2022 we know what's going on here and
some of those questions are the human
conditions still are worth being asked
turn around let me get a look at you
I will be right here when
is running around loose without a
conscience can you imagine the trouble
he's going to get into wouldn't want
that on my conscience everybody who's
anybody who wants to be a somebody that
I want to be real why on Earth would you
want to be real when you can be
[Music]
foreign
asked me quite a few times and I was
reluctant to touch something that's such
a important animated film but you know
all I can say is that a couple things
happen we finally developed the kind of
technology that we needed to really do
it seamlessly and beautifully
re-envisioned it in three dimensions and
photo real way and then one morning I
sort of woke up with an idea for how to
you know kind of put the right kind of
feel on you know the story and once that
happens you kind of have to do it
[Music]
you'll always be my real boy
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we are at the labor party conference and
we're digesting some of the interviews
that we've heard the morning we're
throwing forward to what kirst armor
needs to do to show that he is a
government in waiting with the labor
party and we're joined to discuss all
that by adaptive at Sam coats and also
two labor MPS the labrum people wore
them stoves telecruci and for stratum El
rebiru Abbey thank you great to uh Happy
great to have you here this morning so I
mean in the intro it kind of touched on
that you know Kirsten needs to prove
that labor is ready to govern do you
think that you are on course to win the
next election oh I absolutely think that
we've got a strong case to make and then
frankly if we don't there will be more
years of conservative rule than the last
conservative government that'll be 19
years the conservative government and
for all of us you've seen the damage
that they're doing in our communities
that is a horrifying Prospect I think we
all take the challenge that you have to
be more than an opposition you have to
be an alternative so what we're all
looking to do this week is set out how
to make that happen as I say I'm here as
the chair of the live movement for
Europe we will be talking a lot about
how we could tackle some of the problems
that have come as a result of leaving
the European Union to show British
business that we've got the ideas and we
understand how to make it work do you
think Lowe has done enough to prove to
the public that you're ready for power
I think people are going to want more
because people always want more and
we're going to need to give it to them
and just remember that uh it's gonna
it's gonna take a while to convince
people especially when we're faced with
a barrage of of of press who are on on
the other side
in terms of who they support and the
type of views they put forward about
Labor and the fact actually they like to
go on a lot about some of our internal
struggles we are a broad church we have
always disagreed we see the Tories
disagree all the time it just doesn't
seem to make an awful lot about the
conservatives disagreeing as well not in
the same way I don't think I don't think
so I don't think it's played out in the
same way and I think it always has worse
consequences for us when really we're
just a political party of people
um that goes across a wide spectrum that
disagree on stuff sometimes but we're
all labor and I think that's the most
important thing okay let's talk to Sam
Sam what do you think labor need to do
to show that they're a government
awaiting well I think that they need to
plant ideas in people's minds that that
voters take away from this conference
specifics that are going to make life
different I've got a couple of sorts of
questions couple of challenges sellers
youth as you as you have pointed out you
are chair of uh the uh labor for Europe
one of the big things you could be
saying to get growth going is that
you're gonna ease barriers with the
European Union for growth there are
plenty of people in your party who think
that
but labor just looks to me like it
cannot talk about Europe he doesn't want
to talk about Europe you're a rare
exception why is Labor silent and I hope
you're coming to our big rally at 12 30
today at the Crowne Plaza in Liverpool
where we'll be talking exactly that let
me give you a really good example which
is not the main the main hall you are
that was why we could book
because they don't want the debate lots
of businesses in this country are
struggling with the rules of origin
basically the red tape about being able
to put things into the supply chain
there are things that we could do now we
could join something called the
pan-european Mediterranean convention
overnight it's a it's an organization
has more than European countries and it
would help tackle those rules of origin
things because Liz truss and
quasiquarter have such a Dogma that
everything European is wrong
third of British businesses have stopped
exporting to Europe you can't be
pro-growth if you're not pro Europe so
what we're going to be talking about
today is how labor can lead that effect
we've already led the way on having a
food standards deal but actually we can
go much further to help British
manufacturing now and show what we could
do now to get jobs so would you like
Kirsten to talk more about Europe
absolutely and my job as the chair of
the labor movement for Europe is to
create that debate and put forward those
ideas and say well take up the challenge
because Europe does not want to
negotiate long lengthy treaties with us
anytime soon but they will listen to us
and we show that we are serious about
wanting to work with them and tackling
rules of origin is a great way of doing
that same York's why yeah it's clear
it's fear it's fear because of the
brexit referendum because of the
toxicity that came out of it afterwards
because of what it cost us in the last
general election it fear and just as
with all of these other policies we have
to get over this fear and show people
who we are and what it is we're going to
do for the crowd but can you win if you
think voters are afraid of things that
you say let's take another issue one big
issue at this conference not sure where
they're talking about it out in the
streets that's electoral reform should
there be a change in our voting system
should there perhaps be
teaming up with in parts of the country
the liberal Democrats the SNP in order
to get rid of the Tories do you think
that's a priority what do you think the
party should do about well if it's what
the people of the the conference want to
talk about it absolutely is a priority
we are the labor party we are a
membership-led party that means what the
members want to discuss do you want to
change do you want the party to change
itself well there has to be change
they're 100 has to be changed whether or
not it's what people are talking about
at the moment is another story but we're
not going to know this until we have a
debate about it and if we don't have a
debate there's going to be a lot of
people who are annoyed about not having
debate also no other Alternatives put
forward why why do you want change but
Kirsten doesn't I don't know if he
doesn't want change all I know at the
moment is that we're just not talking
about it which I think is wrong I think
when we see what Boris Johnson's going
to put into the House of Lords questions
about electoral form Constitution reform
will come up again I'm somebody who's
always campaigned for some kind of
electoral reform I disagree on electoral
facts I think that's a different thing
um I think we all recognize our
electoral system you know 40 of people
in this country don't think democracy
works so there is a crisis a political
representation I take your point about
if people at the moment are choosing
between heating or eating can't do
either then our constitutional questions
the ones we want to see us talking about
it's something that's part of being
different I think the priorities for
this week absolutely are how do you help
people who are right now thinking
there's too much month at the end of
their money right we're nearly out of
time so just a bit of a challenge at the
end
um if there was one thing that you want
labor to be talking all about over the
next couple of days what is it what's
your one thing uh cost of living crisis
top thing Stella how we actually get
growth into the economy by working with
our European counterparts and Sam what
do you what do you think they should be
uh talking about kirst armor has got to
implant his vision firmly in people's
minds now this week he's got to work on
this language he's got to work on how he
connects with people he's got to come up
with things that are memorable he's
going to come up with phrases [ __ ]
speeches that people take away with them
that's a bigger test than it sounds
because he hasn't done it in the two and
a half years so far he needs to go up
again really interesting to talk I
always enjoy the take a bit more relaxed
it's really nice to have the opportunity
to have a bit more of a conversation Sam
thank you and thank you very much at
Stella and Bell great to have you on the
program that is it for safe Ridge on
Sunday the take the podcast is going to
be up just after lunchtime so do make
sure you check that one out good to see
you see you next Sunday
[Music]
Dubai is always changing its landscape
we're always looking at new ways to make
sure that people who visit Dubai again
and again have new things to see
Museum of the future for example it's a
stunning piece of architecture but also
has incorporated the Arabic calligraphy
we've just introduced The Deep knife
divide a 60 meter deep pool within a
city to have people as families friends
and groups can go and experience the
post-apocalyptic building
[Music]
today Dubai is proud to have a close to
12 000 restaurants and the first
Michelin guide for the region
Dubai is a city where everyone can find
something that's relevant to them
whether it's a Leisure experience a
business experience or a rest of
relaxation
[Music]
check this out it hasn't been such a
long time since people first started
shopping online and it was easy to keep
up with the clicks little by little by
little by more the clicks added up to be
more than the stores and detailers work
harder than ever before because they had
to keep up with the clicks all of a
sudden there are so many must Do's if
you want to keep selling like delivery
there no there or there and make it
tomorrow first thing no time for borders
gotta stay in control to stay in the
flow and continue to grow but we'll help
you
keep up with the clicks
[Music]
thank you